the Boston bombing happens the New York
Post puts two people on the cover and
says these are the Boston bombers they
weren't the ready community goes to work
diligently I think examining all the
social media and processing it in a
group effort and I just thought to me
this is not really speculation as much
as investigative journalism this is the
greatest thing ever to get hundreds and
hundreds of people working around the
clock to try to process this information
what did you think when you saw the
amount of attention because I think that
was the most public moment for reddit up
until that point what did you think of
that phenomenon well this is the this
illustrated the the gift in the curse of
social media and yes the FBI asked
people for help in identifying suspects
oh sorry yes the the FBI did ask people
to help identifying suspects the problem
is when you create an open communication
platform whether it's reddit or Twitter
you allow anyone to try to help and
participate and very quickly people can
make mistakes that spiral out of control
it that catch steam the the thing for me
is you know as long as humans are part
of the equation there are going to be
errors right just weeks after that the
Navy Yard shooting happened and NBC and
CBS both misidentified someone and these
are hardworking very smart very talented
journalists all this is to say whether
it was amazing journalists doing it or
just random people with cell phones
mistakes are gonna happen and it is the
the onus is on us as users to use these
open platforms as responsibly as we can
to not blindly retweet to not blindly
know the and any of the New York Times
magazine did a very good breakdown of
like tweet by tweet up vote by up vote
of what happened that day and and found
the random it was actually a random
Twitter account that fault first falsely
identified that innocent young man on
the police scanner it was just a total
lie total made-up tweet yeah it got
picked up and started getting retweeted
by legitimate journalists and started
getting picked up and I in a lot of
instances these tools are used for
amazing good a crowd sources amazed
wonderful great things but it's
ultimately people that are doing it and
likewise it can be used improperly so I
you know the the the the unfortunate
reality is there's not a total
technological solution for any of this
is it a net benefit for society though
that people are participating so much or
do you think it's people should just be
quiet and wait for the proper
journalistic you know process to occur I
I think it is a net benefit for society
i I hope that as journalism evolves and
and we're seeing I think cable news is
probably having the hardest time with
this they used to have the monopoly on
our 24/7 attention spans right the first
24/7 news weather was Desert Storm 9/11
anything else was the thing that we all
keyed into now it's the Internet and so
many of them are still trying so hard to
be first that you get what happens
during the Navy Yard shooting you get
what happens when two major news
organizations miss read the Obamacare
Supreme Court ruling like that was
reading text on paper and people were so
frantic to be first the Internet is
always gonna be first it's not always
gonna be right and that's where
journalism really needs to play the
vital vital role in our society of
actually doing the journalism to sift
the data from the noise and what do you
think of journalism today the biggest
sites the highest growth sites things
like BuzzFeed food which people in some
ways group with reddit because of the I
guess the memes or just sort of the
genre but Gawker Business Insider
mahajan post what do you think of those
sites and how they operate yeah honestly
they all do oh you're always gonna get
it real for me i they all they they all
do they all do an interesting job of
curating now I'll snarkily say they
curate a lot of it from various
subreddits from other people's Twitter
accounts from the masses but that's
great I'm happy more of them now a
tribute than they used were yeah it
seems like every third story on Gawker
has hat tip reddit yes they they
grudgingly credit the subreddit or
whatever that sourced it but the you
know it's the same way that's just sort
of polite if someone tweets out
interesting like you'd cite it the one
that's most intriguing to me is actually
upward
and full disclosure I am an investor but
they they have grown I think one of the
fastest growing media companies on the
premise that people want to see and
share positive socially good news and so
they'll find a youtube video about
something that is sort of good for the
world and come up with a great headline
for it and send it out there that's
that's intriguing to me because I really
always I I had yet to see evidence that
something could do better than cat
photos or dog photos or whatever kind of
photos you like and that's that's really
heartening for me it actually shows that
look there's real demand here for
positive stuff not just bleeds it leads
but actually inspiring great news and I
think there is there's still such a long
way to go I'm I was actually having a
conversation with a very smart
journalist about the future of a lot of
these institutions whether it's wash PO
or New York Times and one of the things
that I really want to see them step up
with more is to be that source of record
on almost like you need to know what's
going on in Syria right now here it is
you don't go to Wikipedia for you go
here and and I don't know if I mean
various organizations have done this but
use that clout use those resources use
those amazing journalists to create
things that are the things that get
tweeted the things that get submitted to
Reddit yeah I know but you're seeing in
addition to the listicles and all the
craziness over BuzzFeed they're starting
to hire some real journalists now to do
some actual real journalism so do you
think this is the changing of the guard
like they were using the slide shows and
the reddit memes in order to get the
traffic to get the money to get the real
journalists here yes and what's so
what's so brilliant about it and one of
the great reasons to be an upstart
rather than an incumbent is buzz where
the any new brand can get into the game
with the cat photos and the listicles
and then by doing good journalism be
perceived of as being you know it takes
like Pulitzer and all of a sudden people
are gonna be like okay that's legit
however you could never imagine an
incumbent like the Washington Post
saying alright guys top 10 favorite cat
photos of the week because they come
from a place of such reputation it's
such status that like it I couldn't
imagine even with Beezus in there
actually having that discussion and have
get nowhere but I think there need to be
more and more institutions of new media
of New Journalism that are figuring this
out because it's still far from being a
solved problem certainly on the business
model side and it's so important